esports gonna become as big as football
or soccer baseball and I don't know I
mean that's gonna be really up to the
players decide players do things with
our champions we've ever even imagined
the designers didn't imagine and we sort
of evolved that understanding together
with the community whether you think you
can do it or you think you cannot you
were right what's that believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe that you have the ability to do
something special that can change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from the CEO
of Riot Games Brandon Beck and my take
on his top ten rules of success
[Music]
you have to have an almost idealistic
belief in what you're doing because if
you take a linear logical perspective on
what you're trying to accomplish as a
start-up mmm if that if that makes sense
it's almost the startups almost not
ambitious enough and if it doesn't make
sense than it then it can be like
staring into the abyss of how the hell
is this ever gonna work and you you
there just sort of needs to be you know
oh you know sort of that that old saying
where there's a will there's a way
there just needs to be that that belief
almost idealistic aliy almost not based
in rational thinking that we can sort of
pull this off somehow and at least for
us that was that was key
believing in sort of a nonlinear path to
success it's hard for us to sort of
resonate with with how well the game has
been doing and it's like the ultimate
compliment I mean it is it is the best
feeling in the world to see players
enthusiastic about the product and like
what you guys are here for the the world
finals coming up tomorrow the I mean
that is like a dream come true for us
you know we've always wanted eSports to
be at that scale but we never even
believed that that would be possible and
and you know I remember that one day
like we were in a team meeting we just
got the results from a survey back and
we'd asked players if they enjoy
watching the game in addition applying
it in the number was it's like something
like 70% of players enjoyed watching it
we're like no way that has to be wrong
right we enjoy watching it but that's
what we do we make games like there's no
way 70 and in fact that was an accurate
number and then it was validated by this
sort of the viewership numbers for our
first tournament we're like holy crap
green light for going ape on making
phenomenal on building a phenomenal
eSports experience and that's been so
much fun
to just run with we want the sport to be
big and awesome but I want to make one
one distinction clear like we're not
trying to make this a mainstream sport a
lot of people ask us you know hey guys
is you know is is is our eSports gonna
become as big as football or soccer
baseball
and I don't know I mean that's gonna be
really up to the players aside but
that's not a specific goal but the goal
is to deliver a great experience for the
already large community that really
cares about it so that's the focus the
goal isn't isn't to make eSports as
mass-market or big as possible I think
that's kind of just forcing trying to
force it and it has to happen
organically well this is the the 2004
USA men's national basketball team and
and these guys were stacked right I mean
this was Talent stacked on Talent
stacked on Talent you got LeBron you got
Dwyane Wade you got Carmelo Anthony you
got Duncan Iverson and this would have
been the highest-paid team in the
history of pro sports right but does
anyone remember what happened in Athens
right they got dumped on by Puerto Rico
and then they lost subsequent games to
lift the wane in Argentina I mean they
were they weren't supposed to lose a
single game they were supposed to run
the entire table to the gold medal they
were massive favorites right so while
talent can win you games it is team work
that wins championships back in high
school
I was diagnosed with ADHD so the
classroom was a pretty painful place it
was hard work to spend more than half a
minute's attention in any lecture
regardless of how much I enjoyed the
subject matter and by the way you know I
mentioned it's not because I'm seeking
sympathy but I want to emphasize that we
all have different handicaps and it's
how we choose to handle them that's
what's important we can be paralyzed by
self-pity we can lower our expectations
we can give up entirely but those of us
who choose to power through and simply
opt for redoubling our efforts improve
our chances for success dramatically I
think to really to really make something
something great you have to be
passionate about it so I mean it comes
down to like even like hiring criteria
like when people are joining ragging
there's two things we look for one is
just their aptitude their their talent
and then the other thing is is their
passion I mean we care way more about
those two things than like their
experience for example because we think
that you have to love you have to love
what you do you have to love the game
you have to understand the game -
because it's easy to like come in having
been a really experienced artist or
really experienced game designer but
have no comprehension for how League of
Legends is so different from a lot of
conventional game so we're a lot of
conventional wisdom breaks down geek
culture you know can allow people to
just drift and a strong culture can
serve act is this membrane that keeps
large diverse groups of people working
in alignment and every company every
company has a culture right whether they
acknowledge it and are deliberate about
it or not you know culture is sort of
this living breathing evolving idea and
it takes consistent effort over time to
synthesize you know to codify and then
ultimately to teach and I and I love
this analogy and I'm just gonna yeah I'm
just gonna take a survey real quick but
who in this audience is like me and you
raise your hand if you really like black
licorice okay
handful of you guys all right lot of
people right there now who in this
audience looks at this images like that
is freaking disgusting I hate black
licorice okay
tons of you guys now who in this
audience is like really ambivalent Oh
black licorice would ever have sometimes
okay very few of you right now who in
this audience is ambivalent about
vanilla ice cream you don't hate it it's
not the first thing you order at Baskin
Robbins either okay almost everyone
right and and that's kind of the
difference here you you it as a culture
you don't want to be plain vanilla right
you don't want to be a catch-all flavor
that is something for everyone right
that's dangerous it just waters down
your culture you want to be black
licorice you you want to be cilantro you
want to be
Unni you want to be Brussels sprout
you want to stand for something right
and and then you'll be a magnet for
cultural fits you know and others will
self select out and riot was an
ambitious endeavor for us to say the
least but it was a pursuit of passion
we've always loved video games and we
saw an opportunity to do things
differently and improve the traditional
model high quality high production value
video games had always been this
packaged goods business but we thought
online and multiplayer centric games
would be better as online services than
as packaged goods why did we need to
sell discs anymore
who who buys any of their digital media
their other digital media like music or
video at the store versus downloading
and why did games need to cost 60 bucks
we could make them available for free
and then just sell optional content a la
carte and players could opt in only if
they saw value this would shift the
burden onto the quality of the content
and the experience and games on discs
were static like movies games could
would get printed and then the
developers would literally move on into
the next project or sequel so we thought
game should have live development teams
dedicated to evolving the experience
into reacting to user feedback we wanted
to build a company that saw the world
through the eyes of gamers and had a
commitment to quality and a relentless
focus on the player experience we make
mistakes right as you heard me say in in
the talk a little bit earlier you know
making mistakes is kind of part of our
culture because we feel like if we get
to what we're not making mistakes we're
spending too much time covering our
butts and and we're not moving fast
enough or we're not taking enough risks
but the key isn't it to not make the
same mistake twice and to learn from our
mistakes and to constantly strive to get
better so that's what we that's what's
that sort of our philosophy who in this
audience believes without a shred of
doubt that nothing not technology not IP
not patents not trademarks not brands
not relationships not any asset of a
game company is worth more than to our
company's success than the quality of
our teams if you believe as I said of
that region
a lot of hands that's awesome now raise
your hand if that sounds idealistic you
believe it in your heart we want to
believe it but your mind is just kind of
full of questions those other things are
pretty important okay good we're pretty
sure of this which is great
now lastly raise your hand if your
company your shareholders your
boardrooms all believe this and
internalize it the same way you do
without a shred of doubt okay a lot less
hands now
you know this is where I think we have a
problem as an industry because until we
all agree until all stakeholders fully
believe in the value of our people then
we struggle to prioritize what really
matters and it's gonna hold us back as
an industry from you know our our full
potential it's so rewarding you know to
see the passion players do things with
our champions we'd ever even imagine the
designers didn't imagine and we sort of
evolved that understanding together with
the community
you know when the community creates a
piece of content that just like totally
makes you smile or laugh I think what
they do for us is they just like drive
this this need to sort of live up to the
expectations we got to be worthy of this
kind of passion sometimes we spend so
much time thinking about features
developing something and we lose
perspective and the community can just
keep us honest and those are the times
we try to really acknowledge you know
our mistakes and get better you know I
think we both probably feel a tremendous
amount of gratitude for the incredible
ride we've sort of had together in the
the moments that we've been touched why
you know meeting players and seeing
their passion for leave and appreciation
for a lot of things you know Rhys done I
mean they've helped us grow as people
and as innov incredibly the gratitude
that we have is just there's no amount
of words I could express it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Dennis vang
asked me to I'm also big league of
Legends fan look me up believe team on
the North American server if you want to
do OQ if there's someone you'd like to
vote on for the next top ten check out
the link in the description and go and
have your say finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Nate Lee Morales Nate
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and for having
me on your podcast it was a ton of fun I
really really appreciate the support and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
you know as you shift your attention to
your future and to what's next I want
you to think about this quote from Henry
Ford whether you think you can do it or
you think you cannot you were right
those words are more meaningful today
than I would have ever thought when I
was sitting where you are I had the same
worries about my future as you all have
but what I would like you to think about
is that for the vast majority of you the
limitations on what you can achieve are
to a very large degree self-imposed
whether it is an external voice telling
you that you cannot achieve something or
it's that internal voice of fear and of
doubt that prevents you from pursuing
your passion these can often be more
limiting factors than the actual career
world itself we think it's incredibly
important to be connected to the players
it it has to guide everything we do we
every decision that we make it has to
start with the player philosophy then we
sort of work backwards from there and we
don't always get it right but the closer
we are with the community the more we'll
understand it like some of my favorite
moments are being our meeting players
you know up close and personal at the
trade shows that were at the eSports
events that we're at I've had so many
phenomenal experiences getting to know
getting to know our players and you know
I think that's that's invaluable I mean
it's a phenomenal resource for us as
developers to get that kind of feedback